tout le monde sait ce qu'ils y
retrouvent aujourd'hui sur métro last
night in être autre que la suite de
métro 2033 qu'est sorti en mai 2010 il
semble bon je vous cache pas que j'ai
gardé sur google juste avant aux propos
alors pour ceux qui connaissent pas je
n'ai pas trop l'habitude de faire des
vidéos sur ce genre de jeu mais bon là
je trouvais que ça va un petit peu le
coup depuis le jeu est vraiment super
sympa et super merci
alors donc s'est développé en russie 1
de base de ce qui veut dire que vous
aurez le droit à des gens qui parlent
anglais avec un gros accent russe bien
rigolo c'est assez sympa pour vous
mettre tout de suite dans l'ambiance
en gros il ya une espèce de grosse bombe
nucléaire à la surface l'air n'est plus
respirable sauf avec un masque à gaz qui
fait que tout le monde est réfugié dans
des métros dont le nom du jeu métro last
night voilà alors actuellement pour
mettre dans le contexte on était donc de
l'ordre rouge
je raconterai vaguement l'histoire et si
vous voulez on est on est passé on s'est
fait en gros on est sorti pour aller
voir une espèce de monstre qui est
dehors parce que dehors il ya des
monstres à cause des radiations et c'est
ce trou du cul de monstres et baynuna un
petit peu un petit peu stone engage en
langage se jauge de stratégie on s'est
fait un petit peu stone en gros il nous
a mis une claque et quand on s'est
réveillé en s'est fait défoncer capturés
par des gens arrivent dans la cellule
avec un autre prisonnier on a réussi à
s'évader s'évader et après ya environ
une heure et demie de gameplay pour
arriver jusque-là ce n'être autre ce
n'est nul autre que le théâtre donc une
autre base dans le métro est là
actuellement ils peuvent me renvoyer
d'où je viens
donc on va se faire renvoyer d'où je
viens de twitter me fait juste assez un
petit peu c'est un petit pestacles voilà
avec un petit tour nick est comme ça
bonjour one aux principales salles et
rigolo ouais
donc cibler notre ami non si c'est lui
c'est lui voilà mais qui n'est peut-être
un peu mais croyez moi c'est un warrior
eyepet des fesses bien puisqu'il en faut
cette fois je vais redire donc on
assiste un petit spectacle bon on se
retrouve tout de suite à la sortie aller
voilà faut qu'on aille l'espèce de
mécènes en fait c'est lui il ne
travaille pas renoncer pas le joufflu
moche de là bas il a tout de suite un
peu plus de classe note soitec sa
cicatrice et où c'est un dingue
alors on entre dans les loges je
contourne te vois tu étais passé c'est
terminé tu les aimes plus donc on voit
un peu de meuf deux vêtues salut
d'accord est un pervers sans émotion
c'est hallucinant mais j'avais du boulot
je reviendrai bientôt c'est promis il a
la classe carrément c'est marrant quand
même dans cet univers un petit peu
apocalyptique où les gens sont au musée
du réputé dans le métro pour survivre ya
quand même des cabarets quoi c'est
rigolo
bon en tout cas le jeu est super bien
foutue alors j'ai un petit peu vous
raconter le gameplay quand on sera en
phase de combat ou en phase
d'exploration
là c'est vrai que je n'ai pas montré
plus passionnants du jeu mais bon c'est
seulement maintenant que c'est fini la
première partie du jeu qui était
d'ailleurs vraiment très très longue
alors artyom c'est moi cartonne chez moi
dimanche par manque de femmes cheikh
ndiaye car mon petit resto on ferait
bien d'y aller mais j'y vois un verre
pour fêter notre survie est d'accord il
est complètement barré
écoutez bien son joli accent russe l'a
complètement ça séduit complètement les
gens alors qu'est ce qu'il faut d'accord
faut s'asseoir et boire un verre monde
l'homme qui a pesé pour n'importe quoi
voilà la ligne rouge si vous voulez
c'est de là où je viens alors ils
discutent ce rite qu'on crève la dalle
qu'on tue nos camarades pour rien qu'on
peut pas blaguer sans se faire arrêter
allez prenons un autre vers cet endroit
il est en train de dire que la 12 juin
c'est de la merde parce que lui les
communistes et en gros souffle et il ya
un peu différents clans dans le jeu moi
je fais pas partie du clan je suis
actuellement mais grâce à lui j'ai pu
venir
d'accord donc la hongrie vient de dire
que ici c'est gênant tout le monde
partage tout le monde rigole ya pas de
régie a pas de pauvres bref il vante un
peu son truc à part a redit que le nôtre
c'est le pack merde je veux te défoncer
le voeux au maire d' aller on a eu voilà
comment ça se passe mais on veut partir
je fais mon boulot pour protéger al
helou gtoi le mousquetaire tué devenant
des cô tes soldats en s camarades non
j'hallucine
vous n'avez pas vu le gameplay d'avant
mais en gros lui sauve la vie plein de
fois et nous la sauve aussi elle au
final ils veulent m'emmener quoi allez
dis moi je fais d'accord il a piégé le
vert aux lensois rédac or voilà bon ben
voilà un beau retournement de situation
moi qui croyais que c'était vraiment mon
soit j'ai été intégré
alors ça c'est un petit plus pendant les
chargements même si là c'est déjà fini
il nous raconte en dessous de ce qui
vient de se passer l'auteur donc là j'ai
vraiment été idiot j'ai cru à cette
histoire d'amitié à celle que vivent de
mousquetaire débile attend un peu je me
vengerai je me demande quand même
pourquoi pas mais elle a pris la peine
de le piéger
carrément alors qu'on lui a sauvé la vie
plein de fois et lui aussi nous a sauvé
la vie qui s'offraient c'est ça qui est
étrange qu'on arrête ça il a un peu trop
enthousiastes tiens je te considère
comme un ami mais en tant que soldat tu
comprends je devais suivre les ordres
est amenée ici et maintenant tu en état
d'arrestation mais ce n'est peut-être
pas fini
qu'est-ce que j'ai une chance de
survivre dans la moi tout de suite je la
veux ou namek pas content sur la droite
bühler ben ben c'est pas mal ici par vhf
le camarade moscou venu là on se pilote
plus que tout les troupes de l'état
général il est ici et le camarade 12
buts
alors qu'est ce qu'ils vont nous faire
en fait j
ça c'est comme prisonnier là bas j'ai
mal alors que c'est que ces coïncidences
n'existe pas tu es là parce qu'on a
besoin de toi et que tu as des
informations alors je te conseille
d'être d'accord donc en gros ils veulent
juste ça c'est bien je voyais un gros
gros flux du cliché de l'humanité comme
alors le monde et en bordel mais les
humains trouve quand même le moyen de
s'entretuer sasebo d'accord donc ils
vont pas qu'on te regarde droite et que
sa grosse tête bien grasse alors après
chaque le bunker que vous avez trouvé
celui qu'ils contrôlent et survie et
tant pis pour les autres mais on s'est
passé tellement tu veux l'aider et je
veux que tu me rejoignent eux arthur les
voiliers vieux qu'on aille dans son clan
plutôt que la libye
je crois que c'est ça que moi j'en aï où
je ne suis pas sur ma foi des hommes un
peu partout
j'aimerais bien après une phase un petit
peu de gameplay je vous entends d'ici
peu elle est borgne n'a pas survécu il a
survécu mais de justesse voilà alors
viens nous happer de rencontrer le
général hongrois nous on mais il n'a
rien dit à part aller en mêlant
d'interrogatoire voilà c'est 80 ehpad
surnommé le sombre et d'une grande
importance scientifique dit moi tout ce
que vous savez sur lui je vous laisserai
l'avenir ainsi que votre coach et les
rangers mais en 30 questions tout cas le
mousquetaires un pour tous et tous pour
un truc à nos injecter 10 aiguille ça
pique secrétaire général camarades
mousse green temps au budget de revue
par les narcos qu avons nous là un autre
ennemi de la révolution parfait comme
vous savez déjà alenia de travail et un
pas sa façon de communiquer
toi tu me touches pas vu moustachu ok
alors voix il a dit qu'il allait nous
montrer une méthode de l'armée rouge
sans avoir à nous mettre les sortes de
vérité donc en gros sa méthode sa lettre
de frapper je pense c'est en fait c'est
un sens de notre graphique laisse même
pas parler le gade que voilà bon et qui
veulent se tuent entre quoi est ce qu'on
regarde toi alenia l'interrogatoire
c'est mon travail est quoi je me savais
que son fils est le personnage inverse
de lui un peu non
on a peu de pouvoir sur la place aux
photos feraient a dirigé dans la paix et
les gens l'aiment encore tué un bandit
revient et c'est ça le plus c'est son
fils qui s'est crashé morceaux et du
témoin subit ensuite vais dans mon
bureau il faut qu'on parle donc ça c'est
général typiquement coûts - en fait la
vitalité risques et protéger
l'information
je crois en la science une injection
vous aurez et vous nous direz tant
c'est ce qu'on va voir qui sont ces roms
va bien marcher ou pas
d'accord donc on voit un petit peu la
vie du mec waouh
oh la vache
alors là ça a l'air d'être un petit peu
là
sassi des hunters donc c'est les
monstres qui sont dehors dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure des grosses bébêtes
commuter qui sont devenus deux comme ça
où ça fait mal alors là ce que vous
voyez voilà c'est un gamin qu'un masque
à gaz
d'accord la créature que vous voyez à
côté de moi c'est pas un ami à la base
c'est un monstre hyper méchant qui
bizarrement avec moi est plutôt amicale
parce qu'en fait le personnage que j'ai
on le suspecte donc c'est dans le dr
jean tête de vous faire le prince du
session mais bon je vous raconte quand
même à la base on s'est fait capturer
parce qu'on partait chasser un sombre et
un saut
qu'est ce que c'est cette créature qui
vient de me sauver la vie et à la base
sont des ennemis qui peuvent pénétrer
dans notre esprit mais moi j'ai un
certain contact avec eux et ils sont pas
très méchant avec moi donc voilà qu'un
tueur était localisé des tests dans
cette enveloppe vous récupérez stallman
après le voyage à venise end et ce n'est
pas cette fois côté sur un général voilà
donc on voyait bien de voir ce que j'ai
vu il veut capturer la créature qui
m'avait sauvé quoi je sais pas si je dis
de la mer mais d'après ce que j'ai
compris c'était sarko a pas mon père est
mort aux âmes la révolution et même mon
futur je préférais alors tu es plutôt
guerre comme on perd ce match et son
propre frère bon compte et sous
certaines ici visé c'est tout
ah merci le fils ah ouais d'accord ok
donc oui si on perd c'est vraiment un
martyr quoi nos fiches ton coach
merci en route vers la liberté
je vais en profiter pour vous parler un
petit peu du gameplay alors c'est un fps
on a un petit peu des armes
1 la base d'un fps si vous voulez on
trouve pas mal dame sur les ennemis les
munitions sont assez rares on les trouve
sur les ennemis faut pas trop en abuser
non plus on n'a pas illimitée ensuite la
monnaie du jeu ce sont des munitions
spéciales des munitions soit on peut les
utiliser elles font permal par rapport
aux munitions entre guillemets basique
ou soit on peut les dépenser pour
acheter des armes donc ou améliorées
même ses propres armes
mais bon j'ai pas encore eu l'occasion
de faire ça j'en ai 30 commun 30 37 ou
39 je crois et la première rame est à 45
donc je peux pas d'ailleurs j'ai vendu
toutes les armes comme un gros con en
pensant que elle s'arme perrin parce que
j'ai plus de munitions alors j'aurais pu
juste trouver de munitions ou un peu con
alors la ligne rouge je me trouve dans
des catacombes insisté d'araignée le
secrétaire général moss qui ne me sens
pas du tout avec la mère j'ai atteint ma
exprès bout zut
donc là on est vraiment dans la base
ennemie on va peut-être faire une phase
où on s'en fout
d'accord alors est ce qu'il y aurait pas
ça pas lâcher un truc par terre la la
boîte que j'ai fait tomber par hasard
voilà j'ai mon armure prend le qu'est-ce
qui a déjà servi j'hallucine ducasse et
à jet d des impacts de balles truc mais
voilà là actuellement on est en mode
voilà j'étais sûr que ça fait tomber
quelque chose c'est quoi ça c'est un
masque
bon on va le prendre là on va pas voilà
comme ça on a un masque à temps je pense
que l'oxygène du on va regarder regarder
la monte c'est le temps que j'ai
d'oxygène donc ouais non j'ai que 35
secondes on peut peut-être avoir mieux
remarque non non bombages et 35 secondes
oxygène cdhp dehors 35 secondes allez on
y va fort se la jouer discret à mon avis
vous allez voir qu'on propose des voiles
à des méthodes des phases soit on
s'infiltre ou alors soit on y va à la
bourrin c'est comme on veut par contre
[ __ ] voir ils sont deux est-ce qu'on
peut pas aller ailleurs alors ça me fait
un peu peur de passer par là bas sachant
qu'il y a deux ennemis comme ça non je
suis obligé je suis obligé bon allez on
y va
bon il est juste là ça va être tendu on
va essayer de le faire
enfin une petite phase 2 de combat alors
là j'ai complètement chillon
d'infiltration en passant d'accord donc
mais l'homme qui rage et le moins vite
au monde tu skies se pose ce point de
vue je peux compris la voyant on peut
prendre une deuxième heure voilà on
s'attarde fusil à pompe en salaire
salaire de refuser à pau pour tout cas
j'ai des trucs trop bourrin la vache hop
on allume cigare et fusil à pompe c'est
parfait tout ça vous n'êtes pas d'accord
et ben tant pis
peut éteindre les ampoules un histoire
de bien se mettre dans l'ombre et d'être
bien discret hop c'est parti
c'est par contre bien évidemment on va
pas tarder à se faire opérer à mon avis
un faux pas trop qu'on fasse très mal un
deuxième poste répondait deuxième poste
je suis la danse presse ah bon hop on a
trouvé des acteurs va allumer la lampe
deuxième poisse colle yahoo youtube on
s'en laisse moi tranquille lâchement
attaqué alors on va aller où direction
la gauche gauche tout qu'est ce que vous
foutez ici on va trouver dans les
environs moi ça allait retourner au
boulot et tous on a plutôt intérêt à
saint fêterait là ils doivent être pas
mal nombreux voilà ils sont juste là
attendez on va aller par la up
est ce que on peut faire un multi qu'il
sait quoi on va essayer
voilà merde non tu devant le peuple
ok par contre c'est une balle dans la
tête un club comme ça comme ça le petit
dernier force de fun allez va dans mon
viseur bien là bas aussi
c'est quoi ce qu'on va faire ce qu'on va
faire le tour
on va changer d'armes c'est comme un
petit fusil à pompe up
tu fais quoi se plaît au revoir alors là
tu veux vous dire que c'est assez facile
sauf que le petit trou du jeu c'est
qu'on récupère sa vie vraiment très très
très lentement
c'est assez balèze est d'accord donc le
client satire est allé à les phases de
combat sont voilà donc la jeune ballet
jamais jamais rencontré ce genre d'
ennemi là que d'ondés koubbi un peu un
peu balèze
cassez vous bordel on savait quoi on va
y aller on à succès avec ce soir par
exemple ça qui pète cours voilà je pense
qu'ils sont morts non mais sérieux là
haut où les gars je suis dans la merde
égard crient tous pour m'aider sommes
d'accord une petite balle de match et
aura suffi alors on va ramasser se
disent et les munitions et les armes sur
les ennemis voilà on est plus au niveau
des cartouches de fusil à plomb oh là là
là là on a là bas ça fera un carton
comme ça hop boom
voilà on est bon
au revoir alors voilà vous voyagez
ratant d'infiltration alors autant y
aller de manière plutôt brink et tu sais
toi d'accord temps plus instable un coin
et tu es membre a bien chacun son truc
au revoir est-ce qu'on peut pas j'ai le
réflexe en fait de far cry 2 scoop et
c'est ignoble parce qu'on peut pas
économisé de munitions voilà en faisant
ça j'adore les animations sur un peu
trop disent d'ailleurs que le mec ne
réagit absolument pas coutume poteau
couteau je m'en fous allez on y va
c'est parti hop phase 2 de dégage à sion
on a un masque voilà on a un filtre
parfait on va tenir une minute trente
cinq scénique alsa donc l'appareil vous
savez quoi on va y aller en secrète
alors je sais franchement je ne sais pas
comment c'est possible d y aller en
secrète là-dedans peut-être fort je
pense qu'il faut aller voir vu en
premier je me suis guéri voilà voilà un
l'arène dès que en infiltration c'est
bien moi donc là autant sortir de là
on va pas se mentir autant attendre les
ennemis un par un avec le fusil à pompe
allez voir comment j'ai pu le louper
quoi adacore merde gaz
ok donc là en fait le truc c'est que bon
je vais mourir pas tenir très longtemps
sur maman vous pouvez voir le temps j'ai
une j'ai deux minutes à partir de
maintenant pour réussir mkc après j'ai
plus au tchad et je meurs comme une
grosse merde c'est ça l'histoire mecs
comme toi tu as un casque d'un casque et
les versions une version large version
xxl version collector mres sérieux la
méthode efficace qu au mont dieu l'a
montré le bip que ça veut dire ça non
mais là je vais mourir
simplement avec la liste 48 secondes
me voilà dans de très très beaux draps
est-ce qu'on peut pas voilà à prendre
sur l'ennemi j'ai vu que j'ai pris y
avait quelque chose à prendre la part
ici et voilà un masque à gaz juste là
c'est bon on a trois minutes on va juste
devoir régen un petit peu notre vie
c'est comme essayer de faire les fourbes
d'accord ça c'est plutôt efficace contre
gros balèze
apparemment m à tête 0 revenir les héros
fait le mec didier tout commence à
m'énerver pas
bon ce qui devait être fait a été fait
allez on y retourne cette fois on essaie
le mode furtif parce que là je suis
vraiment très très mauvais mais je
comprends pas comment on peut faire
quelque chose de furtifs quand il ya
autant d'ennemis dans la salle 1 ça
c'est un petit peu le truc qui m'énerve
veut que je suis nul en fait simplement
j'aimerais bien juste finir cette salle
on recommence de ne pas prêts du tout
quand on se veut dire allez hop va tout
de suite
peut-être qu'il faut tout simplement
esquivé en fait aux [ __ ] fait main
attendez je me demande si on peut pas
passer genre là derrière comme ça qu'ils
sont trop bas moyen je pense
si je te lui lui voit si je tue lui lui
la bike merde je voulais juste qu'on
fait tout mon travail
ohlala oh là là oh là là là je suis dans
la merde absolue bon on quitte ground
abbas à trois paniers à léocour encore
au courant mais le masque à gaz
puisqu'il a du gaz détiennent alarme
s'est trouvée tout fait ce dégage quand
une formalité
les gars je vais creed réfugiés comme
gérer toujours nous on y est yamar
massal d'emballage m'en souviens j'ai un
peu car up ou alors on peut faire ça
pour essayer de masquer 1,6 à ses
bienfaits
je dis pas où le petit bug ça va ça en
l'air attendez il faut bien peser dans
la tête cet homme là je crois qu'on fait
un truc bien mieux que tout à l'heure en
fait autant bienvenus cinquante et une
minutes [ __ ] j'ai cumulé du cumul suis
dans la merde
d'accord mais qui sont un peu ta
question des [ __ ] jetant le crâne à
les moeurs mon kiki
voilà il est mort il en reste plusieurs
sûrement
mentir j'ai plus de munitions et une
grenade
waouh men je suis foire et les grenades
science si bizarre
je me casse je me cachais peut-être
moins gros boncourt
on a repris les concours pourquoi mon
gars tu as les couilles qu'ils soient là
haut up on y est ça va sauvegarder voire
pouvoir monter ça le furent en photo une
photo à l'ego mon gars tu l'interdiction
a quand même
alphonse ans salut je te tue au ralenti
pour que tu meures bien au revoir
heureusement moins bien tout compte fait
on va s'arrêter là puisque ça fait quand
même 20 à 30 minutes de vidéo
et si vous regardez cette vidéo que vous
êtes mardi soir c'est que je me suis
arrêtée maintenant sinon le rendu est le
plus dans la vie trop de temps en tout
cas j'espère que ce petit jeu vous plaît
que ça vous plaît des fois de faire des
petites vidéos découvertes comme ça oui
une ou deux fois par mois voilà c'est
toujours sympa ça fait toujours un petit
jeu une petite actualité de plus à
découvrir sympathisants non et puis
voilà en tout cas j'espère que ça vous
aura plu je vous invite à lâcher un
petit j'aime ça vous a plu
on se tourne bientôt dans une vidéo tu
te monde pis